- Well today is emlocated.
So, what does his legacy
mean to you specifically?
- It's, wow.
I mean that's, it's, there's so much,
I couldn't even begin to cover it,
but just all his activism
and everything that,
he did in the civil war for
the civil rights movement.
- Selflessness.
- Selflessness and, just
the human being that he was.
And I'll always respect
everything that he's done,
but in particular, how he did it,
he just uses articulations
and his knowledge
and his charisma, as power.
And I love that.
- Which is true power.
- He knew it was very effective.
It's true power and it was very effective.
And, I just truly, I
mean, I can't say enough.
I mean, we can go on for
this about five minutes.
- I know that's hard to wrap
it up in a synopsis, yeah.
I would never have asked the question.
- But no, it's everything
that he stands for.
And even unfortunately,
even if we listened to a speech today,
we,
- Still relevant.
- Still relevant, still relevant.
We still have a ways to go.
- Amen.
(audience clapping)
Well, you, you visited the motel
where Dr. King was assassinated.
Was that-
- Yes.
- what was that like for you?
- I was there and I said, oh yeah,
I wanna go by there, just to be there
and just to look at the layout
of everything from afar and-
- It had to feel intense.
- It was definitely intense.
It was definitely intense
to know that he was there
and everything that's happened there.
And it was just something
that I just had to see.
And I was glad that I was there.
I was glad that I saw it
and I took a picture of it, of course.
And, I have it up on my wall.
And it's just one of those things to wear,
it's just a moment in time,
to know that I was there where such,
a powerful, effective person
was and, it's very powerful.